[Musique]
pour marc fesneau bonjour merci d'être
notre invité ce matin nous allons parler
des régionales mais d'abord un mot sur
ces chiffres le coc vide a fait un
million de morts
en europe la france va atteindre la
barre des 100000 morts un moment est-ce
qu'il va falloir s'arrêter d'égrener des
chiffres et rendre hommage à ces
victimes ont sans doute un moment
viendra le temps de l'hommage mais le
temps n'est pas venu non mais il ya déjà
des bars et des seuils symboliques qui
sont passés effectivement mais au fond
on est encore dans le combat contre
cette pandémie on le voit tous les jours
il ya près de 6000 personnes qui sont en
réanimation et donc on a besoin on a
besoin d'abord de lutter contre le lac
au vide
et puis de faire en sorte que un moment
régulier on fasse aussi on pense à tous
ceux qui sont disparus du fait de
néolait barre suffisamment fait depuis
le début de cette crise sanitaire aux
amabilités tous préoccupés les uns les
autres
ben dans la face à la lutte contre c'est
une tension entre la lutte contre la
gauche qui le qui doit être notre
préoccupation de l'urgence du de chaque
jour de chaque matin si je peux dire est
que chaque semaine et puis par ailleurs
de penser quand même à tous ceux qui
sont derrière ces nous de ces chiffres
il ya des gens il ya des détresses
humaines ya des familles qui sont
endeuillées donc il faut penser à ça
aussi
en grande bretagne on voit des verts
dans les pubs nous on regarde le
calendrier en se disant c'est loin la mi
mai sans garantie de réouverture en a
raté quoi je crois pas qu'on ait raté
les choses le rythme de confinement du
anglais à d'ailleurs les amène jusqu'au
21 juin entend le souviennent donc c'est
une affaire progressive
vous voyez bien d'ailleurs que sûr cette
épidémie les phase épidémique ou les
pics épidémiques ne sont pas dans la
même temporalité les anglais ont eu un
pic épidémique se rappellent qu'ils ont
confiné pendant noël ce qui n'a pas été
notre cas c'est à dire que quand nous
n'étions pas confiné hull était très
puissamment au mois de décembre parce
que le variant angles est apparu si
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça là bas c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qui s'appelle ainsi
donc on voit bien que les phase
épidémique sont pas les mêmes les
allemands avait confiné puis des confiné
non mais j'ai pas dit qu'on n'avait rien
rater je ne dis pas vous m'entendrez
jamais dire que les choses sont
parfaites mais de dire que de constater
que la temporalité du virus n'est pas la
même même si ça peut paraître étonnante
d'un pays à l'autre
enfin ça c'est la temporalité du virus
sont les choix politiques
non non c'est la tempe il ya aussi la
temporalité du virus après les anglais
ont fait des choix qui était d'abord
celui un moment de l'immunité collective
il ya 130 mille morts chez les anglais
je perds aucun état et aucun
gouvernement ne peut être taxé d'avoir
été parfait mais je crois que chacun
essaie de faire face en fonction de la
temporalité est ce que vous êtes sur la
ligne marc fesneau du patron du medef
qui dit rouvrir coûte que coûte mais
mais même s'il ya des restrictions
sanitaires
oui ça d enfin le coup de que coûte 100
avec des restrictions sanitaires c'est
pas le coup de couteau fond c'est il
faut essayer de rouvrir et faut essayer
de maintien d'activités il faut essayer
que de faire en sorte que nous
retrouvions progressivement des liens
sociaux
mais le coup de que coûte c'est pas au
prix de la santé des français donc il
faut essayer de ce qu'on essaie de faire
depuis devenu de tenir un équilibre
entre les contingences sanitaires et
puis les coups le reste des contingences
qui sont la liberté que nous avons tous
envie de retrouver d'aller à des
activités de travail ou à des activités
plus récréative
vous savez on a eu des communications la
part du porte-parole du gouvernement ces
derniers temps ils ont râlé il faut
tenir encore quatre à six semaines
on a cette échéance de la mi mai on
vient de voir dans le journal de cete
réunion parle de nouveau du variant
brésil est on a des brésiliens on a des
projections d'épidémiologistes qui nous
disent ça va durer après l'été à
l'automne
est-ce que vous alors à la place cayla
vote de ministres mais aussi en tant que
citoyen quand vous projetez ça vous ça
vous désespère ça vous inquiète quel est
votre état d'esprit qu'on vous regarder
devant
c'est plutôt le citoyen même si je suis
mince par ailleurs c'est on voit bien
que cette épidémie est ce virus il
invite à nous rend à être humble parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'on a eu des épisodes
on avait le sentiment je me rappelle de
l'été dernier qu'on était débarrassé de
ce virus et il est arrivé des variants
des vagues épidémiques donc c'est invite
à être prudent dans la phase dans
laquelle on est qui est une phase de
vaccination on voit bien que la
vaccination produit ses effets y compris
d'ailleurs sur la majorité des variants
mais c'est invite à la prudence et je
pense que ce qui qui dans les opinions
publiques françaises comme du monde
andré le sentiment que c'est une un jour
sans fin au fond est quelque chose qui
est assez désespérant mais on s'en
sortira simplement le temps paraît
vraiment très long alors j'ai les maires
on parle des régionales les merceries
donc prononcé pour un maintien du
calendrier régional au mois de juin à 56
%
les maires ont décidé non les maires ont
pas décider parce que certains nous ont
fait le grief de consulter les mairies
quand même étonnant parce que
il est arrivé qu'on nous fasse grief de
ne pas consulter les moeurs et pas et
c'est pas une logique les parlements
qu'on suit les maires les associations
dans l'urgence
c'est vrai que ça s'est fait dans un
délai assez court mais peut-être aussi
parce que il y avait besoin d'écouter
les maires parce qu'on avait eu la
parole des associations d'élus mais
manifestement 56 des % des mères étaient
pour le maintien
d'ailleurs la question qui était posée
c'était pas ma tient pas maintien c est
ce que les conditions de protocole qui
vous sont proposés sont jouables pour
vous et puis 40 % ont dit non ça veut
dire qu'on a quand même réussi au
travers de cette consultation à montre
aussi ce qui était les écueils des
maires il faut il appartient au
gouvernement d'y répondre
et donc c'était important d'écouter les
meilleurs parce que je pense que vous
n'aurez fait défaut la démarche qui
était la nôtre consulter les partis
politiques qu'on sorte consulter les
associations d'élus que de laisser ceux
qui sont en première ligne pour
l'organisation du scrutin
pour l'heure je rappelle que la dernière
fois municipal on nous avait expliqué
qu'il fallait voter voter voter et le
lundi matin suite du premier tour nous
avait demandé pourquoi on avait maintenu
le jour du vote donc que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités donc là c'est une
façon vous voyez tout le monde non c'est
pas la question de mouiller tout le
monde il faut que chacun exprime ce
qu'il a exprimé nous nous prenons notre
responsabilité mais ceux qui avaient
exprimé au moment des municipales y
compris parfois des associations de lui
il faut y aller il faut y aller faut
voter et qui après la semaine suivante
vient de vous faire le grief de ne pas
aller voter
et bien comme ça tout le monde est au
clair et le gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités parce que la question de
la tenue des élections c'est une
question de responsabilité du
gouvernement je rappelle que le texte de
loi prévoit que le vote qui a été voté
par le parlement sur proposition du
gouvernement prévoit un vote les 13 et
20 juin que le premier ministre a dit ya
quinze jours à l'assemblée nationale dit
que le principe de base pour le
gouvernement s'était maintien des
élections ce qui compte quand même c'est
pas seulement le maintien des élections
c'est qu'il puisse y avoir une campagne
et que les citoyens se déplacent pour
aller voter parce que la démocratie
confiné s'est pas seulement pas pouvoir
aller voter la démocratie confiné c'est
quand les citoyens ne s'intéresse pas au
scrutin qu'on peut pas faire campagne et
donc j'imagine que tous ceux qui sont
pour le scrutin au mois de juin ils
feront aussi oeuvre de pédagogie pour
que tous les français ont envie de se
saisir de ces questions a fait
aujourd'hui numéro deux du modem
françois bayrou s'était prononcé pour le
report de ces élections
il était trop prudent non il n'était pas
trop prudent il avait exprimé ce qui
était la voix d'un parti politique et la
voix de françois bayrou qui était dire
attention les conditions n'ont pas de
pour le politique mais les conditions de
la tenue du scrutin appelle une exigence
et une vigilance particulière a eu
raison de le faire
vous pensez que les assesseurs tous les
assesseurs pourront être vaccinés c'est
dans ces dispositions là qu'il faut se
mettre sa masse est intéressant c'est
que la consultation du week-end a permis
d'entrer y compris aux associations
délit que le sujet il ya 140 mille
bureaux de vote puisqu'il ya deux
scrutins 70 mille fois deux ça fait à
peu près 6 à 700 milles assesseurs il ya
la question de la vaccination mais avant
la vaccination et la question
d'identifier les identifier moi j'ai été
maire et donc président le bureau de
vote pendant plusieurs années et
conseiller municipal vous trouvez pas
c'est rare qu'on trouve les assesseurs
six à huit semaines avant donc un
travail à faire avec les élus le premier
ministe essaiera de détail un certain
nombre de choses j'imagine cet après
midi dans cette affaire concernant qu'on
s'organise en amont pour pour déterminer
ce qu'ils vont tenir les bureaux de vote
vous êtes candidat pour la majorité dans
le centre val de loire
je n'ai pas encore déclaré ma
candidature je freine je le ferai dans
les jours qui viennent pourquoi vous
prenez le temps il faut y aller
maintenant
non mais vous vous aurez remarqué que
vous m'interrogez sur les dates du
scrutin que par ailleurs je trouvais que
le moment et il me semble que le moment
est plutôt à la lutte contre la pandémie
mais j'irai dire aux habitants de la
région sens que je vais leur dire
prochainement
comment elle se passe vous imagine que
vous êtes quand même commencé à prendre
la température à faire campagne
comment est-ce qu'on intéresse les
français à ce scrutin est ce que vous
craignez une forte abstention et et
comment se passe cette campagne la
difficulté pour les régionales en
particulier c'est que c'est souvent une
collectivité qui est assez éloignée des
citoyens et les élus régionaux sont
structurellement à s'éloigner
différemment d'ailleurs des des élus
départementaux qui sont plus en
proximité donc un identifier les
compétences de la région
et puis parce que on sait que c'est un
peu les transports on sait que c'est un
peu la formation c'est que c'est un peu
le développement économique on sait tout
ça en fait on ne sait pas vraiment parce
qu'on le perçoit pas toujours et
deuxième élément je pense qu'on a besoin
dans les conditions sanitaires qui sont
d'une autre d'essayer à toutes forces et
par tous moyens je pense que pour tous
les candidats c'est la même équation de
rentrer en contact avec les citoyens
pour leur dire quel est le projet que
chacun porte dans la région c'est oui et
c'est pour ça que c'est bien d'en parler
y compris au parlement parce que suffit
pas de dire on vote faut intéresser les
citoyens à la question du vote est à
l'enjeu de ce scrutin parce que les
régions
c'est très important et les départements
c'est très important voyons poids de la
gestion de la crise du coup vite sur ce
scrutin
en réaction la majorité en tous cas il
ya toujours un contexte national il ya
treize régions dont il ya toujours un
contexte une toile de fond national mais
je crois qu'ils ont aussi des équations
locales qui peuvent se construire
d'ailleurs s'il y avait des c'était une
affaire simplement nationale vous auriez
des
les grandes vagues c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe parce que des présidents
ou des présidents de région qui ont leur
propre part des d'équations locale merci
à vous merci à vous